we are joined now by dr atul gawandi he
is a surgeon at brigham and women's
hospital in boston and a professor at
harvard medical school
he also is a member of president-elect
joe biden's new coronavirus advisory
board and that's why he's here
dr gwandy very good to see you let's
talk about the thanksgiving
travel the cdc has made it very clear if
you want to happy
if you want a happy thanksgiving and you
don't want to have a very unmerry
christmas
under no circumstances should you travel
that said you see people at the airports
you see people lined up at clinics to
get the covet test
in anticipation of getting ready for
thanksgiving what's your message to them
this morning
i'm with the cdc i think that um we're
in a tough place right now
it's over three million people who are
actively infected in the country
um when we're gathering at thanksgiving
the risk of exposure especially in
whether it's in airports uh train
terminals
bus terminals those are high so
taking into account that advice i think
what we know is
we're in a tough place next year next
next thanksgiving and and
christmas will be in a very different
place but right now this is where we are
and even if you get tested today it
doesn't help you for thanksgiving next
thursday right
well that's right i mean look if um we
must
get together you want to keep the folks
you're gathering with
smaller than we might normally at chris
at in the holidays
uh second you would love to crack a
window third you would love to
uh make sure you've quarantined uh for
the for the last about two weeks ahead
of time so you make sure you don't
pass it along a test can help during
that time
ideally close as close as possible to
the date but
you know really the evidence is that if
you gather with 10 or more people
we're upwards of of uh we're upwards of
one out of 100 people having an
infection right now so that means
many families will have someone infected
and they often don't know it
capable of passing this coronavirus
along we need to have that as a strong
message
coming from the very top across the
country this is not
a partisan issue the virus just doesn't
care
dr gawande president-elect biden has
urged the trump administration
to provide his transition team with
critical information
about the pandemic what is your biggest
concern
about this delay in the transfer of
power
well we have two massive undertakings to
address number one is understanding just
as the new president-elect team takes
over
what's the status of masks and gloves
our hospital beds
are resources for taking care of people
i'm talking to people at state level
local level hospital level
nursing homes who are reporting
shortages of staff
about 35 percent of hospitals are short
of staff in eight states
are we addressing that and then you add
on the vaccine distribution
do we have the syringes how are we gonna
allocate who gets
first you know state officials uh don't
have that information in that plan
underway and yet they're being told
be ready in two to three weeks to start
distributing vaccine
that plan is there we need to know about
it and and what are the supplies are we
going to run into
shortages uh over time that handover
this is one of the most massive
undertakings
it can't just be dropped in the lap of
the next administration
the age 20 hhs secretary was here
earlier and he said
the cdc is staffed by career diplomats
they'll keep things going all the
information is public everything you
want is out there
is that true and he said it's not
costing lives
yeah he said it's not costing lives yeah
it it it is absolutely not true this
this is dangerous look
there are uh basic amounts of
information that you just can't
land in your lap to understand here's
here's a case in point
there was a plan for 300 million doses
to be available at the end of the year
what what they're reporting now is 20 to
30 million doses available
why where are the bottlenecks what are
the shortages how are they addressing
them and what are the gaps that
then the next administration needs to
fill that alone
means delays that could cost lives and
getting ahead of it
could save millions of people tens of
millions of people
a chance to get the vaccine sooner so
you don't think the president-elect is
exaggerating when he says this could
cost lives
there is no question uh look look at it
this way
we have deployed about 100 million tests
over the last eight months as one of the
governors in the
meeting with president-elect biden
pointed out we're now trying to deploy
330 million doses of vaccine to people
twice in the next year and trying to
accelerate it happen in months
there hasn't been anything like that
undertaken you don't just simply hand
that over
and think that everything is going to go
smoothly we need planning and
coordination
okay before you go have you been told
when these conversations will begin
they will begin the minute that the
general services administration
ascertains that president-elect biden
can speak to the agency officials
and the transition team those of us
advising them can can speak to those
officials
that doesn't happen until the gsa rules
that is the case
the president current president trump is
putting a lot of pressure
to not allow any of these meetings to
happen
all right dr atul gawandi thank you so
much for your time this morning